we're joined on the line by secretary of
state mike pompeo obviously the
secretary's a very busy day secretary
really appreciate your time sir
ben it's great to be back on the show
with you so let's start by sort of
going through some of the details of the
trump peace plan the deal of the century
obviously you know you would expect the
the resistance from the usual points of
view but what are the actual
kind of bare bones of the plan being
presented by president trump today
ben the president has taken on one of
the longest challenges
toughest challenges in foreign policy
and it is the most detailed
most realistic plan ever presented and
what's important for everyone to know is
there's now a live
offer on the table and this hasn't been
the case before a live offer on the
table for the palestinians to consider
over a four year period i can go through
a bunch of the details for the first
time
there's a plan that ensures israeli
security that's endorsed by the israeli
security establishment
israel will be able to defend itself it
creates a viable path for the
palestinians to get a state
conditioned on a reasonable set of
milestones being achieved over a
reasonable period of time jerusalem
remains an open city
under israeli control and sovereignty
inside the security barrier
and no change in the status
on the temple mount the status quo will
be preserved there
i think this is a reasonable basis for
the parties to begin
to engage in a vision that can lead to
peace and prosperity and security
now secretary pompeo what the plan
really represents for for those who are
knowledgeable about the region at all is
a reflection of just basic realities on
the ground jerusalem cannot be divided
there's no physical way to divide it
when it was divided
in the past before 1967 it was barred to
entry for
jews as well as many christians the the
notion that israel is going to dismantle
major jewish areas
outside of the 1967 lines not only
ignores israel
having an actual claim to that land it's
a disputed claim by the palestinians but
they do have a legitimate claim
it recognizes that israel is not going
to dismantle cities that have tens of
thousands of people
living in them it also recognizes that
the palestinians are not going to be
abandoning the west bank or judea and
samaria or the gaza strip
anytime soon and it recognizes the
security challenges that are faced
with in what is an extremely crowded
neighborhood
that the fact that there are so many
people who are kicking back against the
plan i think
is is recognition of the fact that
people are unwilling to recognize
realities on the ground particularly
with issues like the so-called
right of return this idea that suddenly
israel is going to allow millions of
palestinians to
demographically settle in israel and
then vote for the dissolution of the
state
ben what what we tried to do and what
the president trump tried to do in this
process is to take
uh history into account and the reality
on the ground as it stands today into
account and i think
you just took through half a dozen ways
in which this plan does that
it shows incredible respect and dignity
for the palestinian people
too it simply asked them whether that's
in the west bank or in the gaza strip
to stop paying terror stop inciting
hatred to recognize
uh israel as the as a jewish state
these are these are things that are
fundamental that are facts that are
unchanging
and delivers the possibility of a
peaceful outcome
uh you know there are there's no one
under this plan that will require to
uproot
no israeli will be required to uproot no
palestinian will be required to uproot
these are just recognizing fundamental
facts and we think
presents a basis upon which to build uh
i know there'll be people that will push
back
but what we've seen in the region so far
to date is
a lot of a lot of individuals who had an
expectation for what they thought might
be in the plan
realizing that this vision for decision
for peace and for the region is one
that is worthy of consideration well
this is one of the things about the
peace plan that i find so interesting is
is the fact that there are a bunch of
arab states that showed up
actually brought envoys to this event
obviously oman the uae
there there were several different
countries that actually showed up who
never in the past would have shown up
for anything
right ambassador was there right exactly
and that
that signifies a change in mindset on
the part of many of the arab states that
have been dedicated for decades to the
proposition that the jewish state was
simply going to disappear
suddenly recognizing that that is never
going to be a reality
this has been something that i've worked
on the president's worked on that
jared kushner has worked on for three
years now
trying to make clear that just the the
ordinary nature of what needed to take
place in the region that the threat was
from the islamic republic of iran that
there were shared interests between
israel and many of the
arab states and that there was a path
forward for those states
to to live in peace and harmony in the
region
now meanwhile a quick quick note the the
final question for you the palestinian
authority chief malcolm udabas has
already said that he's rejecting the
plan that of course is not a surprise
since the palestinian leadership has
rejected literally every peace plan ever
presented to them
including incredibly generous offers in
both 2000 and 2008.
so the what exactly is the future of the
plan if the palestinians don't decide to
accept the plan and move forward with
negotiations
in the end the palestinian people are
going to have to make a decision about
whether they want
to continue to difficult challenges they
face today with the absence of
prosperity
the terrorism that exists and the
corruption that has existed in the
region for a long time or if they want
to turn the page
uh and deliver an outcome for themselves
and for the children and their
grandchildren that's better
a brighter future that that that
opportunity is now on the table
but they don't have to do it today or
tomorrow but i'm confident that as they
stare at this as the palestinian people
stare
at what the opportunity is a plan that
might put as much as 50 billion dollars
into their uh places of living a million
new jobs created when they stare at
those opportunities i'm convinced that
the palestinian people will over the
coming
weeks and months and we've given them
four years we'll see that this is a
better option for them i'm hopeful that
they will i pray that they'll make that
choice
well secretary of state mike pompeo i
know that you're on a short time
schedule i really appreciate your hard
work
on this thanks so much for your time ben
thank you so much sir have a great day
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe
button so you stay up to date on all of
our future content